everybody this year Tom Brady did a new
contract with the Patriots and it
created the impression that was an
extension and then a day or two later we
realized it's no extension at all he's
gonna be a free agent in March no matter
what no franchise tag no anything if he
wants a walk away he can and then came
the news that he was selling his house
in Boston and looking at property in
Greenwich right around the corner from
Chris Simms potentially so that the
pieces have already been there for
people to say maybe this is last year in
New England and that's been out there
it's been hovering and we've discussed
it but on Monday night as ESPN was
broadcasting the Patriots Jets Monday
night game Adam Schefter started pushing
this idea a little more strongly than
just speculation that there was a there
was a vibe to it that that hey this may
in fact happen and and look I I'd be
stunned if it does Chris I think Tom
Brady's best scenario is to stay where
he is look at how good the defense is
look at where they are look at how many
championships they've won but the
purpose of this discussion let's just
engage in the hypothetical if he would
go somewhere else to play not just
retire but go somewhere else to play
where do you think he could go where you
would have a shot like he has an hour
everything is set for him to just come
in and do his thing and the rest of the
team and the coaching staff is in
position to take him to the top of the
mountain know where this is a stupid
hypothetical okay I'm not playing along
I'm not it's stup your stupid
hypotheticals that takes two stupid
hypotheticals to make a positive
that's where we're going with this yes
but here's my point here's my point if
you're gonna push the idea okay that
he's gonna leave after this season you
gotta have a destination that's my point
that's so where were there let's what
where would you avoid you can't pick one
day why can't because it's absolutely
insane to think that the greatest player
maybe in the history the NFL would leave
the greatest franchise ever where they
love each other and the owner loves them
and everything's that way and he's gonna
go hey we're in the middle of a we can
win another Super Bowl next year but I'm
gonna leave town and go start over at 44
yeah okay yeah yeah okay so first of all
sorry I'm not not playing along yeah
Stan you understand that this is kind of
how the show works no III the guy's
selling his house if anything the thing
that popped in my head Mike when I first
heard Adam Schefter say this he's a
Michigan guy I thought oh Tom saying
this to add a little frenzy to Adam
Schefter and drive up the price for next
year for his deal that's where this was
going well I think it was maybe a bone
to Brady or a bone to his agent get
teams thinking about it as you make your
plans you know the plans for next season
aren't made next season yeah the plans
are made now they're thinking about
quarterbacks now potential free agents
potential trades potential rookies they
can draft and let's not forget about Tom
Brady and that my read on it is that's
exactly what this was this was kind of a
flare to make sure everyone understands
Tom Brady's in play for next year even
if he's not so now that we've killed
almost the entire segment dealing with
your little tantrum let me identify two
teams I'll keep the two teams last night
and one I thought of this morning after
I had a chance to sleep on it last night
the first team and the only team that I
thought was viable was the Saints okay
Brees is gone after this year right
you've got the defense you've got the
coaching staff you've got an NFC South
division that isn't really all that
great where you look around and see
where things are right now although the
NFC is a lot tougher play to get to the
Super Bowl yes the other team Chris yes
and and this is one that I've always
thought of with Tom Brady and we don't
think of it now because all the talk has
died down about Jimmy Garoppolo being in
a make-or-break season but even though
the 49ers are six and OH Garoppolo is
not having a great year he's like 27th
in average passing yards per game he's
got seven touchdown passes six
interceptions his passer rating is low
in comparison to other quarterbacks and
remember when they made the phone call
two years ago that ultimately resulted
in Jimmy Garoppolo becoming a 49er the
first question from John Lynch to Bill
Belichick was can we trade for Tom Brady
so you throw in he
up in the area he's a 49ers fan he was
at the catch game and if there really is
any type of something between him and
Jimmy Garoppolo wouldn't that be the
ultimate power play to tap Jimmy
Garoppolo on the shoulder and say all
right I you know daddy's home I'm taking
over huh and what other team aren't the
49ers basically the the Patriots in the
NFC right now well they are as far as
results wise but not the way they play
offense you know I mean Tom Brady has
probably not run as many bootlegs in his
whole 19-year career or 20-year career
as Jimmy Garoppolo has just run this
year alone it's just not a fit that way
it's a all the way they asked for him
two years ago because I don't think it
was real I mean these being funny is
facetious you know that I mean come on
oh yeah can you trade away the guy that
just won you the Super Bowl and carried
the team back you're telling me you're
telling me your guy Kyle Shanahan would
say no to Tom Brady no he wouldn't say
no but ever come to that this was an
icer he's staying in the real and I
don't like hypothetical
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports